in the remote western Himalayas there is
little evidence of what led Indian and
Chinese soldiers to the worst violence
in decades India and China shared the
world longest unmarked a border Chinese
military drills like this one have
become more common both sides have
increased their military presence in
recent months with tension rising over
who owns what land the border has been
disputed since India and China went to
war in 1962 the line in yellow is the so
called line of actual control but there
are several disputed areas on either
side one of the main ones is exciting
it's claimed by India that administered
by China China says their shared
interests are stronger than their
conflicts but it also has a warning we
once again asked India to act on our
consensus and strictly disciplined its
troops not to cross the line to provoke
and not to take unilateral action that
may complicate the situation Prime
Minister Narendra Modi says India wants
peace but is ready to defend itself I
want to assure the nation that the
sacrifice our soldiers have made will
not go to waste
for us the integrity of India and our
sovereignty is the most important thing
and nobody can stop us from protecting
them nobody should have an illusion or
doubt and this messer for families it's
a time of mourning this father says he
can't believe his son a colonel is dead
we are under deep shock after hearing
about my son's misfortune I never
expected this he would usually work in
difficult places
[Music]
Indian officials have rejected
accusations they cause this escalation
furious protesters say China must be
punished
while the debate over the border isn't
new the circumstances have now changed
this democracy is a more aggressive
posture by the Chinese which looks like
a deliberate policy to create confusion
between India or rather deteriorate the
relationship between India and China at
the highest level a political divide has
turned violent now raising the stakes
for Beijing and New Delhi over where
their vast frontier begins and ends
[ __ ] hello fissile a yawn
Raja Sara Elizabeth Iran enjoins us live
now from New Delhi Seoul is the besides
say that they don't want this to
escalate what is the latest
it's interesting Rochelle because both
sides have said that they are going to
de-escalate the situation on the border
as soon as possible that's following a
phone call between the two countries
foreign ministers following high-level
meetings between military officials in
the galois Valley but if you look at the
wording from both Foreign Ministries in
fact you could actually exchange the
word India for China in both both of the
statements and you would be reading the
exact same thing they continue to blame
each other in these strongest possible
terms they both say that the other
trespassed into their territory attacked
their soldiers and broke the June 6th
agreement which they had made so that's
interesting to see that because they're
saying that they're going to de-escalate
but that there's no agreement whatsoever
on what happened in the meantime here in
India there are a lot of questions that
are continuing to be asked about how 20
soldiers were killed at a time after 10
days of talks between officials at a
time when the government was saying that
they have the capability to resolve any
border disputes through dialogue and
we're also starting to see you've seen
those pictures of protests they are I'll
be at small lockdown restrictions on the
number of people who can gather are
still in place but there are protests
Chinese flags being burned reports of
residents welfare associations asking
people to throw out their Chinese
products and we've seen videos of people
doing so we've seen the hashtag boycott
China and Chinese products trending on
Twitter and there's also a very -
nationalist media here which has joined
the chorus of calls for the government
to take action against China both to
explain how this could have happened and
also to take action against China all
right well is the puranam live for us in
New Delhi Thank You Liz now Katrina you
has more from the Chinese capital
Beijing China says it's in close
communication with India by both
diplomatic and military channels foreign
ministry spokesperson jolly jian spoke
to the media today on wednesday and said
that both sides were in
and on resolving this dispute through
peaceful dialogue and that China did not
want to see any further clashes at the
same time Dahle Jian laid the blame for
the deadly brawl on Monday solely at the
feet of India according to Beijing the
two slabs actually reached a consensus
on the border dispute On June 6 but
Indian troops violated this consensus
and he said they provoked and attacked
Chinese personnel he also went on to
urge the Indian military to discipline
its troops he won't want to say further
that the location where this altercation
took place the Goldwyn Valley he said
that this was and has always been
Chinese territory something that's
heavily disputed by India and he said
that clearly it was clear that who was
on the right and the wrong side of this
class that resulted in the deaths of
those soldiers on Monday now according
to Indian media there were Chinese
casualties as well but the Chinese
government is yet to release any numbers
and there is some speculation that they
may never release these numbers a state
media here are saying that this is in
fact a sign of goodwill from Beijing an
example of Beijing wanting to pursue
peace with India and not wanting to
spark any confrontational sentiment that
may lead to all-out conflict Aman Tucker
is a scholar at Saint Anthony's College
at the University of Oxford he joins us
from Washington DC we appreciate your
time so much so are there any
indications to you anything that you see
positive in this this perhaps maybe
de-escalating well it's certainly a very
serious time right now but I think the
fact that you know both sides were able
to talk to each other the foreign
ministry is actually talking and the
fact that both capitals are sort of
still saying that they're looking for a
peaceful solution I think that's a very
positive development I also think that
the fact that this didn't escalate
immediately when this incident took
place Monday night to Tuesday morning
the fact that this immediately
domestically is also a good sign but
things do remain very tense and it's a
very serious point that we're at right
now where things could really spiral if
they're not managed and the fact that
both Foreign Ministries are talking to
each other and there is a you know
commitment at least two publicly right
now to talk and to find a peaceful
solution that may be a sign of optimism
that we can hold on to so what are the
sides looking for to be able to publicly
continue to de-escalate what what is
India looking for what is China looking
for well I think the the Indian side is
cut is is made it clear that they'd like
to see it return to the status quo as of
April you know before this latest border
standoff began they say stand-up began
at the end of April so they'd like to
return to the positions that were that
the book armies would withhold before
that point I think China has said that
China said very little so it's very hard
to you know get a sense of what they're
trying to say but I think if they've
reached a position to advantage made
very much like to keep that obviously
now that there's been violence and
deaths on the other border this will be
very difficult to achieve a return to
status quo before the standoff began but
I do think they'll try and return to as
close as they can to the June 6th
agreement that was reached if that's at
all possible and then continue some
confidence-building measures that they
can take to prevent further clashes at
the border that's been a commitment that
both sides have made since the standoff
and Oakland that's when something that
both political both leaders Prime
Minister Modi and President Xi Jinping
had made at their summits in new Han and
in Chennai and that's something that
they'll continue to say out loud but I
think long term what you'll see is a
greater dimension of competition at
least on the Indian side enter into the
dynamic they I think we'll take this
standoff very seriously and while they
may not be any immediate action that
they'll take I think they'll start to
look at China very differently from this
point on and maybe there'll be a greater
competitive element and you get China
dynamic moving forward all right almond
doctor thank you so much for joining us
from Washington DC appreciate your
insight thank you